SIX GOALS SCORED BY VANCOUVER ON
THE ROAD IS BURAKOVSKY,
TAKING THAT DROP PASS.
DISHING IT ONTO THE LEFT WING
NOW.
LANDESKOG WITH IT THE
POWER PLAY AS MAKAR WITH A LON .
THAT TIME, A SHOT BY MAKAR, OFF
INTO THE CORNER DOWN A
LITTLE BIT. THE
CANUCKS NOW TRYING TO BREAK OVEE
PENALTY COMES TO AN ENDSSURE.
WITH GIRARD, GETTING TOKAR, TRY.
WING, CHIPPING THAT PUCK TO THE
,
LETTING GO OF THAT SHOT, NOT TUT
IN.
OUT IN FRONT, WRISTER, BLOCKED,
GOING AFTER IT ONCE AGAIN,
BACKHAND,
OUT IN FRONT, MURRAY, SLIDING ID
ON THAT GARLAND GOAL AND HE WAS
BY KUEMPER!F ONE TOO, NOT JUST
WITH THE BLOCKER! THE ARM UP ANT
RIGHT-HANDED SHOT AND NO PROBLEM
AND THAT GOES DTHEY'VE ADDED ANE
BLUE LINE AND IT IS THE NICE STT
HAD TAKEN
SEATTLE.
AN OPPORTUNITY AT THE SIDE AND
IT IS IN!
IDEA WHERE IT GOES.
LOOKS AROUND.
AND IT IS OFF OF HIS STICK, OFF
OF MURRAY AND MILLER, IN TO HELP
OUT.
AND IT IS RAN ON
DEFENCE, THE AVS WIN CONTROL,
TOEWS WITH THE PUCK AT THE
LINE.
MAKAR NOW.
FOUR-ON-THREE AND LAMMIKKO
DECENT IN THE A
PENALTY BUT ARE NOT GOING TO GET
ONEth IS TYLEROOLMAN, CHECKED
ALONG THEHEO, HEADED TO THEohn T
CHANCE,
BOESER TO PETTERSSON, THE AVS
SHOOTING IT OUT.
VISITORS.
>> John G.: AND WE SPOKE OF THE
BEST LINE FOR THE COLORADO
AVALANCHE, KADRI OUT THERE